SuperMario Odyssey isn't just Mario's
biggest adventure ever or one of the
best titles of 2017 it's also a giant
sprawling love letter to the portly
plumbers video game history Odyssey
might take Mario further than he's ever
been from the Mushroom Kingdom but the
entire journey is absolutely drenched in
callbacks to his long and storied past
just watch out for spoilers this list
goes into just a few of the big
surprises waiting for you a wonderful
wardrobe Super Mario Odyssey lets you
buy a variety of different outfits with
your hard-earned coins that's right if
you've gotten tired of Mario's red and
blue get up or if after 36 years you
figure is simply due for a change of
clothes you can give Mario a makeover
some of the costumes are brand new to
the Mario series but others have pretty
obvious origins the ouija Wario and
Waluigi outfits are all available for
purchase and Mario's classic suit makes
his overalls red and a shirt blue just
like in the very first Super Mario
Brothers you'll also find some fairly
obscure stuff from Super Mario history
the chef's suit recalls Mario's days
baking in Yoshi's cookie the Safari
ready explorer suit is a nod to the Game
Boy puzzler Mario's pick Ross while the
poncho costume resembles Mario's outfit
in the Game Boy edition of quicks as
well as one of his gets ups in his Japan
only anime appearance the painter outfit
references the Super Nintendo tights or
Mario paints the patriotic golf outfit
is from open tournament golf while the
aviator outfit sort of looks like the
clothes Mario wears in his first
portable outing Super Mario Land drawing
that game to shoot him up plane levels
it goes even deeper though and unless
you know Mario's Japanese heritage a few
of these are especially deep cuts
Mario's mechanic outfit is borrowed from
1988's famicom grand prix to 3d hot
rally a japan-only racing game Mario's
fashionable outfit isn't an old
reference but it still weirdly obscure
in 2014 when entender released its new
3ds
it launched a Japanese advertising
campaign starring singer Kyary Pamyu
Pamyu in which Nintendo's classic
characters get brand new clothes
look familiar
celebrating Super Mario maker in 2015
Nintendo rolled out the last 2d Mario
game that anyone would ever need Super
Mario maker the new title flipped the
script and let players officially design
and share their own Mario levels for the
first time and despite appearing on the
underperforming Wii U Super Mario maker
sold over a million copies and boasts
over 7.2 million levels for Mario fans
to enjoy all be impossibly frustrated by
by any measure that's a hit
and one that should keep fans and
amateur game designers busy for years to
come naturally Nintendo put a few
carefully plays to Super Mario maker
Easter eggs and Odyssey like Mario's
yellow and red build a helmet and outfit
which can be purchased a new dong city's
hut shop Super Mario Odysseys other
Mario maker egg is a little more subtle
in some levels you'll run across 8-bit
pictures of Mario and Princess Peach
dressed in cat outfits while the cat
suit first appeared in the Wii U's Super
Mario 3d World the sprites themselves
are from Super Mario maker appearing as
one of the costumes that Mario can wear
in order to unlock the costumes in Super
Mario maker you'll need to clear a
special event in Super Mario wada see
the sprites serve a different purpose
hit them with copy Mario's new hat like
friends and you'll get a small health
boost mario 64 evolved Odyssey owes more
to Super Mario 64 than any other Mario
game since both drop players into wide
open worlds filled with collectibles
platforming is still Mario's bread and
butter but both of those games focus
more on exploration than mechanical
challenges the games are connected by
more than just that though dory the
goggles wearing Loch Ness monster like
creature who floats around the lake
Kingdom made his debut in Super Mario 64
in which players could ride him around
in order to discover new areas in the
wooded Kingdom Mario needs to chase down
some terrified rabbits not unlike a
series of similar rabbit based chases
that take place in Princess Peach's
basement in Super Mario 64 and while
mario stomped his way through various
kingdoms he runs across paintings that
transports him to other worlds which is
a pretty clear reference to Super Mario
64's hanging portraits which serve as
gateways to the games levels and if
there was any doubt Mario's goofy
low-def Mario 64 outfit
here to all Kong all the time most
tomorrow fans know that Nintendo's
mascot first appeared in the company's
1981 hit arcade game Donkey Kong in
which the mustachioed construction
worker had to rescue his girlfriend
Pauline from the big dumb animal the
game's new dong city level is one giant
tribute to that 8-bit ape
Pauline once a damsel in distress is now
nude on city's beloved singing mayor the
city is also full of moving girders and
intrepid explorers will find wooden
barrels just like the kind Donkey Kong
used to throw nude on city streets are
also named after characters from the
Donkey Kong Country series including
relatively obscure ones like Donkey
Kong's animal pals Rambi and rat lay
cranky Kong who is canonically the
original Donkey Kong gets his own Avenue
as well
new dongs City license plates read 1 9 8
1 ND referring to Donkey Kong's release
date and Super Mario odyssey's jazzy
title track a jump up superstar uses the
original Donkey Kong music as a backing
melody and let's not forget about this
when Mario first appeared in Donkey Kong
he was known simply as jump man you
found a power moon every time Mario
finds a power moon
Super Mario odyssey's main collectible
Mario celebrates with a victory pose but
they're not all the same sometimes he
puts up two fingers sometimes he
triumphantly pumps his fist in the air
occasionally he keeps his hand open and
surprisingly there's a little bit of
history behind each one of those poses
the split fingered v sign is what Mario
does after he finds a star in Super
Mario 64 the fist pump hails from the -
Super Mario Galaxy games the open handed
pose comes from Super Mario Sunshine
it's a small touch but it goes a long
way towards honoring Super Mario
odyssey's predecessors after all
Mario wouldn't be where he is without
them toe tapping tunes while Super Mario
Odyssey is full of visual nods to the
series past the game is also full of
auditory callbacks to the past Super
Mario games for example Mario runs
across boom boxes that pump out smooth
jazzy covers of classic Mario tracks if
you use copy to possess the statues in
the sand Kingdom your notice that they
hum little snippets of past Super Mario
soundtracks return to the Mushroom
Kingdom
Odyssey is a big game of lots to do and
of course as with most Mario games
beating Bowser as
the beginning once you defeat King
Cooper and free princess peach the real
challenge begins
not only is every world flooded with a
new set of power moons to hunt down BA
Mario can access a few new kingdoms
including one that looks very very
familiar the Mushroom Kingdom
just like in Mario 64 Mario's home base
has full of things to do with 104 more
power moons to discover which is just
under Mario 64's 120 stars you can
access new challenges through paintings
find a Yoshi hiding on the castle
grounds and even discover a few areas
that look exactly like their 64-bit
counterparts the music is even the same
as he original in addition in a fun
nostalgic throwback the mushroom
kingdoms power moons looked like Mario
64's bright yellow stars
Princess Peach may not be around but it
doesn't really matter after all this
time it's just good to be home
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're love tea
[Music]